public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous thierry solère candidats
avec l'étiquette heller candidat à sa
réélection à boulogne-billancourt et
sans adversaire dans marche pour la
république est l'invité de cette
émission bonsoir
thierry solère et merci d'être avec nous
pour l'épreuve de vérité donc cette
émission que vous propose chaque semaine
public sénat avec radio classique les
échos et l' agence france-presse vous
répondrais ce soir à jean francis
pécresse deborah claude et oriane
mancini avec trois grandes questions qui
vont vous être proposé d'abord le début
du quinquennat qui est encensé après le
baptême du feu réussi sur le plan
international par emmanuel macron ne
naît pas d'éthique pas ternie au final
par par la fée richard ferrand deuxième
question la scission du parti et l'eire
qui fête ses deux ans aujourd'hui même
est elle inéluctable en raison notamment
de l'attitude compréhensive de certains
dont vous envers le chef de l'état enfin
troisième question les primaires dont
vous avez été un artisan engagés sont
elles selon vous définitivement morte et
enterrée après le fiasco que l'on
connaît à droite comme à gauche
d'ailleurs mais d'abord donc les
affaires
m
[Musique]
et avec moi donc jean francis pécresse
pour aborder ce chapitre qui s'impose
dans l'actualité et qui peut même gommer
la campagne actuelle des législatives
peser en tous les cas sur les
législatives
comme ce climat des affaires à peser sur
la présidentielle thierry solère les
soupçons d'affaires donc avec richard
ferrand marielle de sarnez et d'autres
députés européens le ministre de la
cohésion des territoires réfute ce soir
toutes les accusations qui sont portées
contre lui sur son mélange des genres
ses liens d'intérêt il rejette les
soupçons donc détaillé notamment par le
journal le monde alors que le canard
enchaîné enfonce le clou sur l'opération
immobilière à brest avec le compromis de
vente avait été signée par richard
ferrand lui-même peut-il tenir selon
vous alors que les appels à la démission
se multiplient à droite comme à gauche
moi je pense trois choses la première
c'est que toutes ces histoires à chaque
fois créer un soupçon dans l'opinion et
que en démocratie le soupçon c'est un
véritable poison et c'est très mauvais
collectivement dans la confiance qu'ont
les français dans la vie politique où la
deuxième chose que je pensais qu'à une
jurisprudence qui datent d'edouard
balladur qui est un membre du
gouvernement qui est mise en examen doit
quitter le gouvernement
il est présumé innocent endroit toujours
mais il doit quitter le gouvernement je
pense que c'est
c'est bien que ce soit ainsi parce qu'on
n'est pas en capacité quand on est
ministre on est mise en examen d'assumer
la charge ministérielle que président la
république et le premier ministre confie
troisième chose je vois que le
gouvernement le président de la
république le premier ministre prépare
nous dit on une loi de modernisation de
moralisation de la vie politique
ben écoute et j'attendrai de voir ce
qu'il ya dedans par le sait déjà
comme à l'environnement à mesure les
grandes mesures ont été présentées par
françois bayrou lui-même d'ailleurs
écoutez moi j'ai pas encore vu pardonnez
moi c'est peut-être moi qui ai pas été
très vigilants je n'ai pas encore vu
plus conseil des ministres et une
présentation de ce projet de loi il ya
des articles de presse qui nous parle de
différents sujets moi j'attends raid
voir ce qu'il ya dedans pour pas que ça
soit en font un écran de fumée
une loi nouvelle de plus qui n'apportent
rien et donc à partir de là là je vous
ai interrogé sur le cas spécifique de
richert sur le cas spécifique alors il
arrivera il n'est pas mis en examen le
sujet il n'a pas été saisie est ce que
vous comprenez quand même que le premier
ministe matignon selon ce qui a été
rapporté cet après-midi conserve sa
confiance à ce ministre qui est dans la
tourmente au jeu
lui et en parlant que vous aurez alors
qu'en vérité vous savez bien que la
tension monte en coulisses c'est rien
moins de contrebande en coulisses en
tout cas ce que je constate c'est que la
justice pour l'instant suffisamment n'y
a pas d'information judiciaire vient d'
enquête préliminaire d'après ce que j'ai
lu qu'on est dans un état de droit il
faut laisser des magistrats faire leur
travail
non et que donc s'ils devaient être
mises en examen dans cette affaire parce
qu'il aurait eu un délit j'imagine que
le premier ministre et de président la
république en tirer les conséquences qui
quitterait le gouvernement de cette
année et vous défendez même le statu quo
actuel ceo richard ferrand
à ce jour je pars gouvernement je pense
que c'est sain qu'un membre du
gouvernement qui est mise en examen
quitte alors qu'il a la prison 6900 son
âme a vu des gens disent en examen qui
ont quitté le gouvernement et qu'ils ont
été relaxés par les tribunaux mais je
pense qu'il est ça et je pense que ce
gouvernement ne changera pas de règles
d'accord on vous pas de procédure de
justice
donc il n'y a pas d'affaires même si sur
un plan moral alors voilà c'est donc la
différence entre le droit et la morale
et donc la politique on nous annonce
donc une loi de moralisation
est-ce qu'il ya des pratiques dans la
vie politique qui si elles sont légales
ne sont plus acceptés par les français
oui je le pense probablement et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut une loi probablement
pour faire changer la loi pour que ces
pratiques qui sont légales mais qui ne
sont plus édités par des français n'est
plus court sur un point le calendrier
est ce que cette cette loi ou ses
projets doigt parce qu'il semble que en
fait il y aurait trois textes différents
et ce qu'ils doivent impérativement être
présenté au conseil et aux français
avant le premier tour des élections
législatives où est-ce que vous
accepteriez qu'il le soit entre les deux
tours
on va peut-être après le plus tôt il
semble qu'ils aient des je comprends
très bien votre question me suspecter
vrai pour nos cycles et directement moi
je ne suis pas à donner des conseils
dans la république et au premier
ministre
je suis député et je suis candidat à
l'est républicain à boulogne billancourt
à ma réélection moi je
prendrait en tant que parlementaire je
verrais bien la majorité qui est
installé à l'assemblée nationale et je
verrai bien de cette majorité le
gouvernement les texte qui nous
proposera le texte qui nous est annoncé
un gouvernement et des doigts philippe
qui vient d'être constitué est un texte
qui permettrait à les entendre mais je
ne les validait ce qui n'est toujours
pas disponible alors j'y reviens quand
même voir les améliorations
il mesure je le connais et je vous le
dis je vous dise très clairement sur ce
texte comme sur tous les textes et je le
dis à mes électeurs dans la plus grande
clarté oui je voterai toutes les mesures
qui vont dans le bon sens pour le pays
si il ya par exemple on fait par exemple
si les républicains devaient ne pas
avoir la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale je ne m'opposerai pas aux
ordonnances sur la révision du code du
travail à savoir ce que ça va dans le
bon sens mais sur la loi de moralisation
et là il ya un certain nombre de points
qui ont été mis sur la table et que l'on
connaît comme l'interdiction pour un
député pour même un parlementaire en
général d'employer des membres de sa
famille est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre il ya l'idée aussi de limiter le
cumul des mandats dans le temps et ne
vous êtes pour ou contre
s'il te pourrait limiter aussi les
activités de conseil de conseils trois
questions donc la première donc c'est
sur la limitation dans le temps
oui la limitation dans le temps je vous
le dis très sincèrement je pense que ce
n'est pas une bonne idée je ne suis pas
sûr que ça soit constitutionnel trop je
vois bien l'immense problème qu'on a
surtout dans ma famille politique qui
entraîne serait d'ailleurs de décalage
générationnel
oui je suis le seul parlementaire des
hauts-de-seine de droite et du centre à
ne pas avoir plus de 68 ans donc vous
prêcher un convaincu pour autant je
pense que ce n'est pas très
constitutionnel et j'ai souvenir
tu connais sur public sénat le jour où
robert badinter et jean pierre fourcade
ont quitté le sénat je n'ai pas été
persuadé que ça a été une avancée
démocratique formidable ces deux
personnalités apporter formidablement à
la vie démocratique
la deuxième question elle est sûre
sur les emplois familiaux un gros les
emplois familiaux et puis ses activités
de conseil vous aviez été d'ailleurs on
le rappelle ou même mis en cause par le
canard enchaîné alors est-ce que vous
accepteriez de voter ces mesures
l'activité conseil moi je n'ai pas
d'activité pca écrite que la réflexion
globale a évolué sur ces sujets la vôtre
aussi un moyen a évolué depuis longtemps
il ya des activités de conseil au
parlement qui existent moi j'ai cessé
toute activité de conseil du jour où il
ya une nouvelle loi sur la transparence
de la vie politique et je suis très
favorable à leur interdiction pour une
raison très simple quand on est avocat
avec en départementale on peut avoir des
activités dans son cabinet d'avocat par
exemple qui ne seraient qui créerait des
conflits d'intérêts et comme par nature
l'activité d'avocat permet une
confidentialité ce n'est pas formidable
donc je suis favorable à la suppression
des activités de consultant ça c'est la
première chose et deux sur les emplois
familiaux où je pense qu'il faut cesser
ces pratiques par contre je ne veux pas
être hypocrite
il ne faut pas simplement faire cela le
vrai problème n'est pas de savoir si
c'est un cousin si c'est un enfant ou si
c'est un parent le vrai problème c'est
de savoir si c'est fictif ou pas et moi
ce qui me paraît très récent les gaffes
et vous-même d'ailleurs votre épouse
avait été bien sûr mon épouse a
travaillé avec moi ils leur le sujet
c'est de savoir si ces filles qu'il faut
pas est ce que les gens ont ri
qualification ma femme a fait sciences
po l'intérêt cesse de droit gagne deux
fois moins en travaillant avec moi que
en travaillant dans son ancien travail
donc tout ça n'a pas difficulté la vraie
difficulté séquence effectifs ses
conseillers cela vous créez un soupçon
formidable et donc la vraie mesure c'est
bien sûr parce que le symbole est
important de cesser d emploi avec les
proches mais surtout d'assurer un
contrôle comme dans n'importe quelle
structure publique ou privée en france
que ça sophie radio classique et public
sénat
quand on est salarié d'une structure on
y est très heureux alors le début du
quinquennat c'est aussi on l'a dit jean
francis le baptême du feu d'emmanuel
macron sur la scène internationale le
bisou a réussi son entrée un seul on en
suit la presse si on suit la presse
française et internationale face à ses
homologues trump et tous les autres et
hier flasse place à vladimir poutine à
versailles et face à lui une vérité qui
dérange le kremlin on écoute le chef de
l'état j'ai une relation exemplaire avec
les journalistes étrangers encore
faut-il qu'ils soient journalistes
et les responsables politiques ont des
responsabilités de prendre des décisions
de dire les choses quand des organes de
presse répandent des contrevérités
infamante ce ne sont plus des
journalistes ce sont des organes
l'influencent russia today et scout nick
ont été des organes d'un flux ans durant
cette campagne qui ont à plusieurs
reprises produit des contre-vérités sur
ma personne et ma campagne
est ce que vous avez nuit hier en
regardant le président macron un
sentiment ou font un sentiment de fierté
les médiations moi je voudrais plus
encarté cette campagne présidentielle a
été absolument chaotique
je n'ai pas voté pour emmanuel macron
que j'ai voté pour françois fillon au
premier tour j'ai appelé à voter pour
amener le maquereau à 20h01
quand il a été candidat face à marine le
pen au soir du premier tour et je juste
on était heureux qu'il soit élu et que
le front national était écarté du
pouvoir depuis il est président de la
république et quoi qu'il arrive aux
élections législatives il sera le
président macron pendant les cinq
prochaines années le visage de la france
à l'international et c'est lui qui
présidera notre pays et je préfère amont
de mon pays à toute autre considération
est donc je me réjouis à chaque fois
qu'une décision va dans le bon sens et à
chaque fois que les choses se passent
bien sûr la visite de vladimir poutine à
paris je m'en réjouis parce que j'avais
un mal vécu je pense que ce n'était pas
l'intérêt de la france sans pelé ni
partisane avec le président hollande à
l'époque le fait que la france rome en
vrai tout discussions diplomatiques avec
la russie
rappelez vous la faire des frégates que
nous avions refusé de livrer et donc le
dialogue est rompu au fond la diplomatie
n'est pas de trouver des gens bien ou
pas bien la diplomatie c'est de défendre
ses propres intérêts stratégiques et on
ne défend pas ses intérêts stratégiques
en discutant pas avec un le président
d'une très grande puissance comme celle
de la russie
j'ai trouvé le démarrage diplomatique du
président mac rend tout à fait à la
hauteur et c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
la france et donc je m'en réjouis
merci beaucoup jean-francis
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'afp bonsoir
deborah bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes constructif
thierry solère à qu'elle vous fait
partie de l air est ce que vous êtes
macro compatibles parce que ça veut dire
je suis un député de droite et du centre
c'est tout le président disait qu'il
était de gauche et de droite
ben moi je suis de droite et du centre
est ce que je préfère mon pays à toute
autre considération la réponse est oui
le président macron a été élu il donc
légitime
moi je souhaite la réussite de mon pays
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
arrivée à l'assemblée nationale si des
habitants de boulogne nous font
confiance je porterai toujours les
valeurs qui sont les miennes
dans quel groupe je suis républicain je
n'ai pas brevets des républicains a
donné je suis à l'organisateur des
primaires de ma famille politique
la seule chose qui m'importe encore une
fois c'est qu'on ne soit pas ce qu'on
est trop souvent gauche et droite depuis
quarante ans dans notre pays dans des
postures politiques moi j'en ai entendu
des députés de droite quand on était
dans l'opposition qui disait quand on
est dans l'opposition on s'oppose
même si le texte est bon et d'écouter ça
c'est fini parce que je me considère que
la situation notre pays nous impose de
prendre nos responsabilités et donc à la
verve de beaucoup je le dis à mes
électeurs dès aujourd'hui sur les sujets
économiques sur ce qui renforcera la
sécurité des français sur la fluidité du
marché du travail sur la baisse des
charges valeur das des impôts voteriez
les ordonnances la réforme assure qu est
ce que vous pourriez voter d'autres dans
le programmes des manuels macron
éventuellement dans un groupe d'appui à
l'assemblée nationale toute mesure qui
donnera plus de sécurité plus de
compétitivité économique à notre pays et
plus de renforcement de l'état régalien
en dans le caveau donc d'un groupe
d'appui comme le dit déborah donc c'est
la question que l'on vous pose est-ce
que selon vous au lendemain des
législatives
la scission de votre parti l air est
inéluctable ou pas on a constitué
ils ont constitué j'y ai adhéré dès sa
création à l'ump et à l'est républicain
aujourd'hui en 2002 il a la présence de
jean-marie le pen au second tour de la
présidentielle c'était une stratégie
d'union de la droite et du centre dans
la même famille politique pour nous
permettre d'avoir une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale on sait ça ne m'a
pas échappé à personne je pense que la
droite
le centre ont été éliminés dès le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle avec la candidature de
françois fillon donc bien sûr qu'il ya
une crise importante vraiment une des
renouveaux par des biens sociaux une
scission
moi je ne suis pas dans une logique de
ce site tout de suite de se scinder ce
que je cherchais à convaincre et à
discuter avec mes collègues en leur
disant on est un parti issu du gaullisme
on est un parti pro-européen on est un
parti qui défend des valeurs de liberté
économique d'autorité les temps voulait
que l air et moi je ne veux pas remuer
le voit dans d'autres considérations
sinon c'est pas on est plus à l'aise un
autre choc est ce que vous à titre
disons personnel vous payez pas votre
ouverture d'esprit votre côté
constructif à la présidence à la
présidence du groupe de la région ile de
france puisque vous l'avez quitté cette
présidence est ce que c'est pas le prix
aussi à payer de cet engagement comme ça
plus une droite plus vos choix de bon
sens là comme vous l'avait répété après
géant caractéristiques deborah claude
jeunes en muse pas mais par contre je la
revendique je suis quelqu'un de très
libre
je ne dois mon élection de député de
boulogne billancourt qu'aux habitants de
boulogne-billancourt j'avais été
candidat face à claude guéant en 2012
qui avait été parachuté dans ma ville et
je dis ce que je pense aux électeurs
s'ils ne se reconnaissent pas qu'ils ne
sont pas sur la même ligne que moi
probablement de votre ils ne voteront
t-il pas pour moi et vous n'avez les
jeunes sont à la marche n'est pas non
plus le candidat socialiste et candidat
de la france je vous avais été débarqué
de votre présidence de groupe au conseil
général
ça augure de violences à venir entre
nous avec valérie pécresse on passerait
arrive rarement quand même si tous les
enfants des autres groupes qu'il ya des
élections à la présidence des groupes à
ça fait un an et demi que j'y suis et en
discutant avec valérie pécresse on a
tous les deux une volonté très forte ne
pas apporter les débats qui peut y avoir
de sens commun au parti démocrate avec
d'autres tendances de la droite au sein
du fonctionnement de la région
ile-de-france pourquoi parce que valérie
pécresse avec son équipe elle redresse
la région depuis maintenant 18 mois et
il ne faut pas que ça change la majorité
des régionales de valérie pécresse élue
des hisser le modem mais mai dernier
dans la majorité présidentielle c'est
les républicains entre le parti
chrétien-démocrate et moi il ya sûrement
des groupes plus que des nuances tout ça
c'est très bien on va sa région donc je
ne veux pas qu'on apporte moi j'ai
souhaité me consacrer pleinement à ma
campagne législative et abandon et quel
est votre premier argument alors je vous
rappelle et je vous rappelle que je suis
l'un des quatre députés de droite
qui a voté la loi qui restreint le cumul
des mandats donc je suis aussi cohérent
avec grégory quel est votre premier
argument de campagne quand vous êtes le
terrain dans votre sur le terrain dans
notre ville marché dans les marchés de
boulogne billancourt quoi vous êtes là
pour défendre le programme de l ère où
vous êtes là pour dire que vous êtes
prêts à soutenir le chef de l'état
quelle est votre première arguments
auprès de vos électeurs très simple les
habitants ils me connaissent bien c'est
très simple vous allez voir et je
l'écris noir sur blanc dans ma
profession de foi je leur explique que
si elle est majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale bien sûr nous gouvernerons le
pays
président de la république le président
et je leur explique que de droite je
suis dit que j'ai toujours été mais que
je veux que mon pays avance et que donc
si nous devions ne pas majoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale ce qu'ils ont très
bien compris
les françaises qui s'est passé
l'élimination de françois fillon et
l'évolution aujourd'hui politique je ne
serai pas un député destructeur dans
l'opposition bête et méchant vous attire
pas d' insulte on voudrait pas de
traîtres mais en rien au contraire les
français vous entre faire il préfère
rien d'autre qu'un redressement de leur
pays les accusations vous avez deux
réunions les ténors entre vous avez 9
millions de pauvres 6 millions de
chômeurs du terrorisme et de la sécurité
est ce que vous croyez qu'on peut
attendre cinq ans a voté contre des lois
qui vont dans le bon sens tout ça parce
que la majorité dans lesquels les
français auront choisi n'est pas le
groupe dans laquelle vous appartenez
on a eu une année électorale terrible on
a maintenant ce jeune président emmanuel
macron qui préside le pays pour cinq ans
on a un gouvernement c'est pas rien avec
un premier ministre est issu nos rangs
edouard philippe
c'est globalement ce qu'on avait deux
murs magasin disons-nous les choses la
seule chose qu'ils veulent si les
républicains ne sont pas majoritaires
c'est que ça avance
c'est que ça marche donc moi je suis pas
en marche mais joe que ça marche et est
ce que vous êtes également pour la
position qu'il a apprise hier soir sur
le désistement républicain en cas de
menace qui n'est pas le cas dans votre
circonscription mais de menaces de
victoire du front national tout à fait
cette petite évolution il ya eu quand
même des atermoiements après après le
second tour
là il ya une petite évolution moi
j'avais mal vécu je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs publiquement que mon parti
politique forme un peu tort qu'ils y
aient à prononcer le nom d'emmanuel
maquereau au lendemain du premier tour
quand on a le front national est aux
portes du pouvoir au second tour d'une
présidentielle et qu'on est soi même pas
qualifiés dont la droite française on
appelle clairement à voter pour révèle
macron je les fais à 20h01 deuxièmement
gilles boyer
qui est le candidat aux législatives
achats films dont l'agrément département
voisin de circonscription et un matin
proposé qu'il y ait un débat dans ma
famille politique autour justement dans
cette histoire de désistement qu'un
triangulaire pour ne pas favoriser si on
n'a aucune chance de l'emporter
l'élection des députés frontistes après
le premier oui car elle est tout de
suite
r au lendemain du second tour et j'étais
très heureux de voir que françois barois
est exactement sur la mine que je
partage un sondage avait alors je
comprends pas une chose parce que vous
avez dit à l'instant que helder filipe
c'est ce que vous avez de mieux en
magasin vous venez de le dire mais c'est
pas françois baroin qui postulent
également à matignon c'est pas mieux
maintenant ne se situe pas à matignon le
1er mai il quand même idée c'est un peu
ce qui a été indiqué se serait pas vu
plus tôt il serait pas bien merci gambon
dieu ne postule pas à matignon françois
baroin a toutes les qualités pour être à
part les ministres mais on ne postule
pas à matignon le président le premier
ministre et nommé un président de la
république issu d'une majorité pour sa
paroisse fait un grand travail pour
essayer de porter nos 577 candidats mais
vous voyez bien que c'est difficile et
commande ça ne le serait pas après
l'élimination des douanes et au delà
présidentielle de la trémie politique
encore une fois on respecte isme pas du
tout ça s'appelle du réalisme et je
soutiens moi tous mes collègues
républicains qui sont candidats c'est
pas facile bien sûr après ce qui s'est
passé mais encore une fois moi je
préférerai toujours mon pays à mon parti
et je dis à ma famille politique auquel
j'adhère depuis le premier jour à qui
j'ai consacré beaucoup d'énergie pour
leur faire une primaire de bien organisé
on va en parler là dit qu' il faut
vraiment en sorte de ces postures
politiques parce que le pays doit se
rendre à coeur mais qui est le leader
politique dans votre famille est ce que
c'est françois baroin est ce que c'est
laurent wauquiez qui est un petit peu
conspué les gens qui allaient à la soupe
ces dernières semaines comment on voit
aussi à l'assemblée nationale l'avenir
du parti
vont collégialement demandé à françois
baroin et que j'ai bien voulu le faire
il est sénateur et président de la mef
d'être le chef de file de cette campagne
des élections législatives et l'avis des
républicains continuera après il y aura
des débats y aura les élections internes
tout ça est très intéressant aujourd'hui
ici est le meilleur en magasin et vous
vous sentez plus proche des manuels
macron que de laurent wauquiez par
exemple si je voulais pas répondre
je n'arrive toujours pas les choses
comme s'installer dans ce qu'elle juge
complètement à côté moi je suis européen
profondément je considère que l'avenir
de la france ça passe par l'europe avec
un faux pas mais renforcer l'accent sur
un plan économique je suis favorable à
une autorité de l'état importante et je
déteste les phrases élevé et les
résultats faibles
xavier bertrand dans une interview ce
matin la voix du nord estime que madame
électrons n'est pas du tout dans une
logique d'union nationale il le dit
comme ça mais il fait simplement de
l'ouverture un comité rang 88 ou sarkozy
en 2007 et il n'a pas envie de s'ouvrir
aux autres selon xavier bertrand ça
n'est pas votre avis non je pense pas ça
l'ouverture c'est ce qui avait été fait
notamment d'un quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy là c'est pas de l'ouverture on a
nommé et mais le président la république
a nommé edward philippin vers l'union
nationale assez en tout cas à nommer
quelqu'un qui n'est pas issu de son
majorité à lui comme président de la
république donc il cherche de toute
évidence à rassembler différentes
personnalités différentes forces
politiques
il s'adresse plus aux français je pense
le président qu'au parti ils essayent de
constituer une majorité pour deux
projets et moi au parlement encore une
fois par an de vous le dire aussi
clairement
j'assume de vous le dire ce n'est pas
des stratégies à vannes 3 bandes c'est
très simple c'est beaucoup plus simple
que ça j'ai 45 ans je viens de passer
cinq ans à l'assemblée nationale je
trouve que le pays va mal
la seule chose qui m'importe c'est que
le pays a le mieux dans quelques années
et puis après l'ouverture
meetic c'est vraiment une révolution il
le faut il faut que nos collègues
parlementaires d'où qu'ils viennent
arrête les postures et soit dans
l'efficacité de vote et les bas fonds il
est important que le pays aille mieux
dans cinq ans dit vous c'est
effectivement essentiel thierry solère
parce que si le président de la
république réunit une union nationale si
c'est l'échec
l'alternative ce sont les extrêmes donc
il ya un vrai danger
yara ne vous inquiétez pas l'élection d'
emmanuel macron n'enlève pas la vie
démocratique dans cinq ans yaron
prochaine présidentielle est par nature
il y aura des offres politiques qu'ils
sont
la table et le président de la
république comme ses prédécesseurs sera
jugé à l'aune des résultats qui sont les
siens moi ce n'est pas un homme que je
veux soutenir c'est mon pays je serai
heureux quel que soit le résultat de la
prochaine présidentielle qui l'est moins
de chômeurs en france dans cinq ans
qu'il n'y en a aujourd'hui qu'il n'est
plus de sécurité et que la france est
mieux répondu à la menace terroriste est
d'aller répondu depuis quelques années
merci beaucoup deborah aller dernière
partie de l'épreuve de vérité avec
lauriane mancini depuis le sénat qui
nous rejoint maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir oriane michel pour soir thierry
solère vous avez été un artisan de la
primaire de la droite et du centre
les deux finalistes de la présidentielle
n'était pas issu de primaire benoît
hamon et françois fillon qui eux ont
remporté leur primaire ont été éliminés
est ce que pour vous les primaires sont
définitivement morte et enterrée
je le crois pas d'abord je ne suis pas à
l'origine du fait de faire des primaires
alors je suis celui à qui on a chargé
d'organiser un dîner c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui président du parti qui a
proposé à tout le monde de faire des
primaires et il m'a chargé de les faire
d'eux les primaires ça règle pas tout
les primaires ne vous donne jamais la
garantie d'être présent les primaires la
maison trois intérêts la première elle
crée elle règle preuve du leadership
vous imaginez si on avait eu alain juppé
françois fillon et nicolas sarkozy tous
trois candidats au premier tour s'était
même pas envisageable que qu'on ne soit
pas qu'on soit présent klein detroit 113
ans c'est un problème qu'il ait besoin
de régler ce problème du leadership
non je crois pas non je crois pas je
pense que d'ailleurs quand il ya
quelqu'un qui incarne un leadership très
fort fait de faire des primaires ne nous
pose pas de problème vous êtes proches
de bruno le maire qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé son entrée au gouvernement
d'abord je suis proche ou et des bonos
d'edouard philippe énormément qui est
vraiment mon ami on a beaucoup travaillé
ensemble d'ailleurs à la primaire à
edwards était le représentant de damas
juppé et puis c'est très générationnel
avec gérald darmanin avec d'autres on a
énormément travaillé en fermant
maintenant relation de grande confiance
ils font une analyse qui est de rentrer
tout de suite au gouvernement parce
qu'on leur a proposé d'y rentrer n'était
pas candidat aux élections législatives
et considère au fond de ce capharnaüm
convient de
vivre depuis un an il est maintenant
temps où nous avions croisé
j'ai pas besoin mais j'ai dit que je
comprenais la démarche qui était la leur
il est en tout cas je n'ai aucun doute
qu'ils doivent philippe bonnet le maire
et et gérald darmanin ils veulent faire
quelque chose d'utile pour le pays
et puis je regarde mal à vous dire que
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle d'avoir un
mini de l'économie un mini du budget
comme à edouard philippe comme et
d'ajustement lady est vraiment à
quelqu'un d'une immense qualité morale
intellectuelle
quelqu'un qui qui qui qui a un vrai sens
de l'état et qui n'est pas là uniquement
fin qui n'est pas là du tout déchirer
pour la gloriole ou je ne sais quoi qui
est là pour faire des choses et ça c'est
bien après les français vont choisir
leurs parlementaires librement
tranquillement et encore une fois que
tout ça soit utile justement un bruno le
maire un qui est donc devenu ministre de
l'économie pendant la primaire dans son
programme il se défend des notamment une
baisse de la csg aujourd'hui il va
devoir mener en oeuvre le programme d'
emmanuel macron qui lui prévoient une
augmentation de 1,7 pour cent est-ce que
c'est crédible pour le nouveau ministre
et l'économie de défendre ce alors qu'il
a dit contractant de moi bon d'abord ya
trop d'impôts en france
voilà il y aura 22 milliards
supplémentaires en tous les cas même si
un allègement bien sûr sur les actifs
voilà mais il ya trop d'impôts en france
ya trop de charges sur le monde du
travail et à le choix de la tva il ya le
choix de la cge qu'un exemple de deux
reproches difficulté chose qu'il faut
c'est que l'économie reparte c'est comme
ça qu'on arrivera à baisser la fiscalité
il faut être cohérent partir du moment
où ils s'engagent dans cette affaire et
il faut qu' une solidarité
gouvernementale et c'est le président de
la république qui a été élu
soit on se détourne de son pays on
s'occupe d'autre chose soit on fait de
la faire le contraire les trois postures
on attend dé moi je vais vous dire vous
être en position possible
vous voterez vous voterez se trouvait
par exemple sur la hausse de la csg qui
va frapper les retraités et puis les
indépendants est ce que vous voterez ce
texte par principe à un texte
c'est notre cohérence globale fiscale
moi je ne voterai pas des hausses
d'impôts qui ne permettent pas de faire
redémarrer l'économie ça n'aura fait
l'objet de la saison vous avez vous
serez vous espérez que c'est courageux
alors je pense trois choses avec en sus
une chose profondément par rapport à
votre question de fond qui est qu un
député de droite
après ce quinquennat dans la situation
qui est celle du pays il a trois
solutions soit il retourne à ses
activités
antérieur et professionnelle soit il
passe cinq ans à faire de l'obstruction
si on est à majorité a soit ils essayent
de faire avancer le pays
et si vous voulez faire avancer le pays
sur des mesures qui correspondent à vos
valeurs à vos convictions l'a
visiblement ce n'est pas le cas de bruno
le maire est ce que ce n'est pas un peu
d'opportunisme de sa part mais vous avez
vous partez du principe que tout est
figé qu'il n'y aura pas de discussion
tout est écrit vous savez exactement ce
qui se passera à tous moi je vous dis
part du principe qu'elle manuel macro
est parti pour tenir ses promesses et
augmenter la csg mais il y aura pas de
tva sociale par exemple que dans le
programme de françois fillon mais c'est
à l'occasion de la primaire y avait jugé
plus qu'elle était solide et candidats
principaux qui proposait une
augmentation de la csg crds qui en avait
c'étaient des mesures qui étaient tout à
fait envisagée moi je pense que c'est un
défaut majeur
c'est notamment ça pèse sur le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités notamment des plus
modestes parce que le niveau auquel ils
sont touchés et quand même un niveau de
pension qui est quand même très bas
alors dites-moi quand même on a compris
que vous parliez régulièrement peut-être
depuis leur nomination et d'un philippin
bruno le maire à gérald darmanin c'est
le cas j'imagine nice échanger avec vous
échangez aussi avec alain juppé aussi
j'imagine car il vous a apporté
aujourd'hui son soutien
par un tweet enseignement votre démarche
constructive alors en fait vous nous
dites que il est aussi en manoeuvres en
coulisses l'ancien premier ministre un
de manoeuvre d'après alain juppé est un
homme d'état qui a de grandes qualités
il n'a pas d'autre ambition détenir de
bordeaux je crois il l'a dit dans la
plus grande clarté
il veut pour son pays le meilleur est
tout ce qu il ira dans le bon sens il
aura le soutien on n'est pas enfermé
dans des postures partisanes voulait de
livres la mise beaucoup plus que nous
vous croyez moi à oui non oui donc il
est vraiment au sida il était en soutien
des actes et moi j'étais radical a mis à
part son soutien aux élections tiens
d'alain juppé à nathalie kosciusko
morizet mail de calandre ses proches et
vous et moi j'ai beaucoup de respect et
d'affection pour alain juppé j'ai été
très heureux de travailler avec lui dans
le cadre de cette primaire c'est un
grand monsieur
c'était un excellent maire de bordeaux
mais c'est un homme d'état et encore une
fois je sais que j'ai toujours la
capacité d'appeler un ajouté quand j'ai
pas des idées claires sur quelque chose
pour lui demander son regard et je me
réjouis de son soutien moulins de
villancourt continuer sur sur ce sujet
edouard philippe le premier ministre qui
est un de vos amis vous nous l'avez dit
va aller soutenir yves jégo le candidat
du pays qui ne sont pas estampillés la
république en marche je dis est ce que
vous souhaitez également qui viennent
vous soutenir bon ça pour ça que je
soutiens d'edouard philippe qui est un
ami personnel et qui me fait que le
meilleur pour les élections législatives
mais beaucoup de privas était à boulogne
billancourt il ya invité permanent à
vous d'être billancourt autant qu'il le
souhaite
il va venir et au couteau je jouais pas
je peux encore qu'elle est sage à vaison
l'import look est venu ce matin mais et
françois baroin au talent de l'avenue
tessa worley a affirmé dimanche pour me
soutenir a pu l'être billon qu il était
encore une fois tout ça c'est très
intéressant
les électeurs ils sont grands ils
comprennent beaucoup mieux ce que tout
le monde croit la situation ce qu'il
faut c'est leur dire les choses mais pas
leur mentir et faire l'inversé après ce
qu'on avait dit pendant la campagne moi
je dis les choses clairement
en votant pour moi ils savent pour qui
va tailler le message est bien passé on
va regarder un tableau avec tous les
candidats que vous affrontez quand même
dans la 9e circonscription des
hauts-de-seine merci beaucoup
oriane merci thierry solère on vous
retrouvera on
on verra à l'assemblée nationale où
ailleurs
enfin manifestement prêt à soutenir de
manière constructive l'action du nouvel
exécutif on vous a compris merci bonsoir
à tous et en salle
[Musique]